le jour se lève sur Kiev au son des
bombardements nouveau pilonnage de
l'armée russe qui poursuit son
encerclement lent et méthodique de la
capitale ukrainienne les combats font
rage dans les faubourgs
sont très disputés sur ces images
satellites les maisons incendiées
laissent peu de place au doute les
habitants eux évacuent ou se barricadent
interrogés sur France 24
affirme que les forces Ukraine en fait
la cible des forces russes les Russes
tentent d'encercler encerclés qui pour
pouvoir faire un siège
mais
nous sommes d'armes les soldats
ukrainiens ont détruit les plans russes
et nous sommes très fiers
d'avoir des soldats extrêmement solides
qui défendent nos maisons notre vie
notre pays
au-delà de Kiev plusieurs autres villes
comme tchernivicolaïf et Mario Paul ont
subi cette nuit les bombardements de
l'armée russe Mario Paul port
stratégique situé près de la mer d'Azov
acier depuis des jours les habitants
manquent de tout à l'image de cette file
pour récupérer de l'eau selon l'OMS la
situation humanitaire y est
catastrophique le président ukrainien la
firme les Russes bloquent l'accès à
l'aide alimentaire
je dois le dire avec peine Mario Paul
est toujours bloqué par l'ennemi
les troupes russes ne laissent pas notre
aide humanitaire rentrer dans la ville
et elle continue à torturer notre peuple
le peuple de Mario Paulo les évacuations
de civil était en forte baisse vendredi
à Mario Paul selon les autorités
ukrainiennes à peine 7000 personnes ont
pu quitter la ville